my life from when I was 10 to 15 years
old was just a hell hole I was the only
one of my kind at school I was Tiny I
was just a tiny kid I was the only white
kid at school everyone else spoke
Spanish everyone was so much bigger
everyone had body hair except for me
they were a foot taller than me that
explains the beard now you're like
I'm beating it up man thank God this is
you that's me at 15. bro you're not a
tiny kid at all you're talking about
well by the way that's 15 and this is
what I'm getting at and so so what I'm
getting at is
um every day I'm getting kicked out of
me and I don't fight back not once you
know people are just punching me and and
many times faking ass whooping well many
times I got knocked out and and the bell
had already rung and I got a fight by
bug bag half the time they hit it most
of the time it was in the trash can I
already [ __ ] know my book bag's gone
it's probably in the trash can and then
you got to try and figure out what
period is it what class am I supposed to
be in most of the time you go to the
wrong class